true or false Disney produced a short
film called the story of menstration in
1946 trying to trying to teach people
especially in 1946 they're like yeah
this is probably before the PC age and
everything also I think Disney was
Wilding back in the day you know you had
Donald Duck as a Nazi it was it was
crazy in 1946 though feel like I feel
like that's got to be true I wouldn't
yeah that's like that was early days of
Animation they're like yeah let's make
some sex and I'm sure it's I'm sure it's
also pretty wrong so yeah for sure true
on that one then all right we're go true
I just really hope mickeey Mouse is not
in it or I guess it's all about Minnie
dude we went with
true oh bam Disney wilding out in 1946 I
guess